we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started okay so um
many of you have asked me to talk about
this i've gotten dozens of emails a
handful of voicemails a bunch of
messages during live streams saying
david you really need to investigate and
talk about some of the claims that are
being made by members of congress and
their staff
that some aspect of the trump riots
suggests some kind of inside job or
coordination either with members of
congress or
um it with with law enforcement and i
think it's very important
it would be irresponsible for for me not
to say that at this
point what we have is a set of
allegations many of which are still
being investigated and sort of nebulous
but this has
come to a level where we should talk
about it so there's a few different
things going on here
first of all there have been concerning
patterns of posts and communications
involving some
right-wing members of congress in
particular new congresswoman
lauren bobert and it sort of exceeds the
scope of this segment to go through the
minutia piece by piece but you can
easily google this and sort of explore
this path yourself where uh she
appears to have been communicating and
putting out
information that could just be
sort of generally supportive of the idea
of
of a big protest which is what donald
trump is claiming he did but it ended up
inciting a riot
or maybe based on her being pictured
with some
individuals that seem to be riot folks
maybe she was in some way connected or
involved and there are sort of a number
of allegations along that front
there is also the very disturbing
allegation that has come
from a capitol hill staffer that
office panic buttons were removed
in advance of the pro-trump riotous
insurrection her name is sarah grow
she's the chief of staff of democratic
congresswoman
ayanna pressley and she said that she
along with others were taking refuge
in ayanna presley's office as protesters
and rioters
flooded in and that they barricaded the
door
with furniture and they were in there
and then they looked for the panic
buttons
and the panic buttons were gone uh
saying every panic button in my office
had been torn out
and saying they could not find any
rationale as to why that took place
saying they've used them before that
they had not switched offices and that
there were panic buttons
in that office which were subsequently
gone um
what is the explanation for that we
don't know we we simply don't know at
this point in time it's being
investigated
and it should be investigated we also
heard
from congressman james clyburn and james
klein clyburn explained and i'm going to
play a clip for you momentarily
that he has a marked office
at the capitol which says congressman
james clyburn that's
that's his marked office but that as
majority whip
he uh tends to work at an unmarked
office in a different part of the
building
and that somehow the rioters knew
exactly where to go even though it was
an unmarked office
this is him explaining it take a listen
to this the next part of this
which is what makes this even more
troubling with what you were sharing
with our folks this morning
uh part two of this of what you were
reporting about is talk about the damage
to your offices you have two different
offices in the capitol explain it to our
viewers
well i have an office in the capitol uh
which is in
the so-called lincoln room named after
abraham lincoln
that office that's my name on the door
and it has majority whip above the door
and it's just off of statuary hall
anybody walking through statutory hall
can see that office
now that's not where i do most of my
work
up on the third floor is where i do most
of my work and there are many members
of the united states congress right now
who could not tell you where that office
is
and could not find that office if they
needed to
yeah i i've been there it's hard to find
sir
i agree it is not easy yes yeah
but they found it nobody touched the
door
uh where my name is
but they were on the floor and my staff
is inside my
inner office with furniture piled at the
door
with people trying to get in that did
not let them
in my question is how did they know
where that office was
that to me needs a thorough
investigation
and i do believe uh that
for some sensitivities here there were
people uh taking
uh selfish
uh with these insurrectionists
something's wrong here right so again
very troubling allegations the
explanation
for which you know individually any of
these
stories might have some explanation
that's relatively benign
i've not heard it yet and so i i want to
be
again as i've said before an unending
unsatisfiable endless skepticism
uh gets us into conspiracy theory
territory where both evidence for
and lack of evidence and evidence
against all is all as evidence for the
conspiracy
i'm not gonna fall into that at this
point i've seen
enough that says to me
i am not understanding why these
different things
took place if indeed they took place as
they are being alleged and it certainly
needs to be investigated and we've
since learned uh about a number of
different
officers involved with the capitol
police capitol police officers who have
been suspended
and uh are being investigated for their
roles and
we already know it's not within the
realm we beyond the realm
of reality that capitol police
uh acted at least some people
incorrectly
during this and it must be investigated
how far this goes i i think that that's
roughly and i know that
many of you wish i could be more
definitive about this that's basically
my thought about it at this point
in time the allegations are troubling
and if they are true or even part of
them are true
there's quite a bit of explaining that
needs to be done we will continue
following it
upcoming is absolutely no surprise to
anybody donald trump
is issuing a directive that his lawyer
rudy giuliani not be paid for his work
on election fraud so-called election
fraud for donald trump and
this is not um surprising to anybody
there are still questions as to whether
trump was completely serious or only
partially serious when he said this
but it's it's sort of ironic in a sense
because at the very beginning of all of
this we heard oh rudy giuliani is
billing 20 grand a week to fight this
completely fruitless
pointless bogus fight uh over so-called
voter fraud
for donald trump but just because he
wants 20 grand a week a day
just because he submits a bill for 20
grand a day to donald trump doesn't mean
that he's going to get necessarily paid
and we suspected that because donald
trump has a very very long history of
not paying his vendors
and we've heard before from would-be or
former trump lawyers
that they want clients who pay their
legal bills
and so now uh once again apparently
irritated with being impeached a second
time which happened two days ago and we
discussed it yesterday
donald trump has told people stop paying
rudy giuliani's legal fees
um trump i i actually don't really even
know what the connection is that trump
believes exists between him and peach
the second time
and rudy giuliani rudy giuliani was
fighting the bogus fight
that trump hired him to fight and
rudy giuliani did speak and talk about
trial by combat at that completely
misguided rally on wednesday morning on
january 6th
but it was really trump who said let's
go to the capitol and
incited that riot so i don't even know i
don't even understand the connection
between trump being irritated with rudy
over the second impeachment but as we
know donald trump is unable to take any
responsibility
himself and blames people around him
and the reports are that he's blaming
a lot of people in his inner circle inc
including rudy giuliani and others for
the predicament he finds himself in
and at a certain point it may be as
simple with trump as i blame them
because they didn't prevent me from
doing the things i did
and saying even though i did them it's
really someone else's fault because
someone else
i hired other people to prevent me from
getting into this kind of trouble
i don't know uh trump campaign senior
advisor jason miller
sort of said trump is not soured
on giuliani but when he was more
directly asked
is trump directing giuliani not to be
paid jason miller
did not deny that he said i just spoke
with president trump
and he told me rudy giuliani is a great
guy and a patriot who devoted his
services to the country
we all love america's mayor but no
denial whatsoever of the allegation that
donald trump is saying do not pay
rudy giuliani one other aspect of this
john eastman
is this conservative attorney you might
remember his name we talked about him i
believe it's only once before on the
show
john eastman falsely told trump mike
pres
mike president vice pence vice president
mike pence
uh could block the certification of joe
biden's win that was not true
and we are now hearing rumors that john
eastman might join donald trump's legal
team what the point of a legal team is
in the last
five days of the presidency i don't know
but these are just preliminary
discussions uh
what would be the plan there and
this again would go towards this idea
that trump if you can tell trump what he
wants to hear
you get yourself into his inner circle
and this is
arguably why trump's press secretary
kayleigh mcinanny
has has lasted as long as she has lasted
because she has shown
an unfettered unmin unmitigated
willingness
to repeat any lie for donald trump
and to defend any action by donald trump
never ceding an inch never conceding
anything
and that's what trump wants and so now
reportedly john eastman
has some ideas of things trump could do
what they are i don't know
and there are rumors that with just five
days left in donald trump's presidency
he may be joining he may be joining
donald trump's team
for what uh some are calling a
a challenging chapter yes
that is certainly an understatement and
trump increasingly isolated and
desperate to find
anybody that will indulge his wackiest
and wildest notions
we're down to just a few days my friends
just a few days to go and then he will
be gone at least officially
but we will see to what degree donald
trump remains in the public eye
we have a great show for you today make
sure you're following me on twitter
at deepakman we will take a break and
have a
fantastic program for you coming up the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so we're getting down to the very very
end of donald trump's
first and only presidential term
and we will be covering the inauguration
next week i know there are lots of
people with many questions thoughts
ideas about what we've been seeing
so let's hear from some of those folks
via our
discord server which you can find at
davidpakman.com
discord let's start today with val
from san diego hey val what's going on
hi
how are you hey how can i
hi is this uh david yes this is david
oh wow david um so basically
i have a kind of easy question because
i'm actually getting ready for work
oh okay i don't want to keep you no no
it's okay but
um also if i talk too much i tend to
confuse myself so
okay i want to keep it short please so
basically
um my my question
kind of came up to me when i was talking
to someone close to me
and um basically they were talking about
how they touched base with someone from
amazon right
can you hear me well i can yeah yeah you
can go right into the question even
so basically the page the that that
person was telling me how
they talked to an amazon patient right
i'm sorry
customer service person because they
wanted to have like a 10
shipping refund and they explained to me
the whole process of
like how they chatted with the person
and how
basically they were able to give him the
refund um
because he complained about the customer
service and
what i was very very surprised and
shocked with
was how at such a low
type of well people consider it low
level jobs some people do but i consider
customer service really important
but basically some people um
um basically what i thought was
interesting was the fact that you can
actually track a whole conversation down
to one
customer service representative right so
they are now accountable for what they
said
right and i was thinking literally i
think i told him
i was like dude wouldn't it be amazing
if like
i could have that at my work so that
i know that i didn't say anything mean
to a patient
so they could track it you know and if
everyone had that sense of
accountability
like the people who went into the
capital
like it would be so much easier i don't
understand how someone from amazon has
to have way more accountability
than the people who actually broke into
somebody's
place of work is essentially what
happened well
a lot of them are getting caught because
they ended up on camera and they ended
up recorded but but you're making a good
point which is that the default and part
of this unfortunately
is because of surveillance capitalism as
described by shashana zubat
who we talked about i don't know that we
should be cheering
about the the level of uh of data
collection
that you describe with amazon although
certainly they're going to have
transcripts of customer service but
how are we getting away without more of
it at the capitol
and fortunately enough people were
recording things that people are getting
caught arrested and charged
yes exactly but to me what's shocking
is not shocking but it's like
interesting for us to know
you know how in america or the united
states of america
yeah how it's possible that
someone who has like most of the time an
amazon employee doesn't have this huge
education you know how is it possible
that someone with low education
probably is working just to make ends
meet you know
someone like that how can they be have
way more responsibility and get in more
trouble than some people
you know like that i feel yes i think
you're absolutely right val there are
definitely some uh
inconsistencies there in terms of uh in
terms of accountability val i appreciate
the call i hope to hear from
you again uh why don't we go
next to eric from texas eric you're on
the air
hello can you hear me yes i can alright
so i want to know
pardon me um as a new generation enters
politics what would they bring to the
political sphere i i don't know i mean
that's
that's up to them right that's a hard
question to answer i mean i think
the uh can can you say more i i don't i
don't know i'm not sure i don't know
which generation you're referring to
yeah
like generation z and millennials yeah
yeah i mean listen i think that uh we
for a very very long time in the house
senate in law at the state level
we had a lot of folks making law related
to technology
who didn't totally understand a lot of
those same
technologies uh there's these child porn
examples from when
there were people who didn't even really
understand it making the law and then it
led to
bizarre loopholes and you know that's
just kind of one little example
i do think that as our lawmakers more
and more are the people that
grew up with the technologies that kind
of govern much more of our society
that we are going to see that taken uh
much more seriously
lindsey graham i remember at one point
was on the technology
committee or something telecommunication
i don't remember what it was and he had
never sent an email in his life like
that just
that's crazy that doesn't make sense
it's a joke we become a joke you know
so i think that's certainly something
that that will be different i also think
it's going
to be increasingly a generation that
it's not a generation of
socialists but it's a generation that
grew up
more open to different sort of economic
infrastructures and ideas and i think
that that will also bring a very
different approach i totally agree
yeah all right my friend thank you so
much for the call
great uh great question we're taking
calls via discord
at davidpakman.com slash
discord let's go next to
um where are we going next there's just
so many interesting folks wanting to get
on
why don't we go to shane from victoria
canada
shane you're on the air
shane from victoria canada you're on the
air
i i hear you in the background there
shane did you want to talk to me
all right so shane is gone let's go
instead to tyler from st
louis tyler you're on the air
hello david um so
i don't know exactly the subject of
everything but uh
i was wondering is there anything to the
arguments
that universal healthcare would lead to
lower quality of healthcare
well that's what i tend to hear but i
never explained
never explain causal relationships there
the best
the best i've the best stuff i've read
about this
is uh from the late uve reinhardt
who wrote that basically imagine a
triangle
you you're familiar with a triangle i'm
sure and you know that it has
three corners does that make sense
the three corners of healthcare are cost
quality and access and that
no matter what system you support
you are basically picking a midpoint
between those three
so for example if you want to make it
really
cheap and give it to everybody uh
quality is going to go down now it could
still be
better quality than we have and we might
still be spending more you know like we
spend a lot so
this is just theoretical i'm building
the theoretical framework so if you want
to give it to everybody and make it
cheap there's going to be some sacrifice
in terms of quality all else being equal
if you want to make it cheap and really
good
then to some degree you have to restrict
access you understand so everything is
kind of a balancing act and so
when we talk about universal healthcare
if you want it to be
universal um and you want it to be
really good it's just going to be more
expensive now
a lot of people will hear me say this
and they'll say david that's not true
look at how much we spend on medical
billing and
there's profit motive and then there's
all these levels of bureaucracy and then
because some people don't have health
insurance hospitals raise prices
and make them artificially high that's
all completely true that's
absolutely and completely true the i'm
just saying all else being equal
if you want to make it high quality and
available to everybody it's going to
cost some money and it may be
it may be a reasonable amount of money
for example i would be okay with it
being expensive
if we've actually eliminated all of the
waste and the bureaucracy and all of
these things
it's just as a decision as a society
that we have to make and so
that's the sort of triangle you have to
think of it's all just picking a point
between those three
corners and saying here is where we want
to be
okay thank you and uh by the way if you
ever end up in st
louis make sure to try st louis style
pizza
is that a thing or is that a joke well
it's a thing it's really good
what it what's what are the
characteristics so
it has its own we have our own cheese
called provel
okay and it's like it's like a mix of
provolone and swiss and american cheese
um people say it's an acquired taste but
i don't know i've always liked it
well i'm up for trying it yeah and then
it's cut it's cut into squares
and i don't know about that it's got a
very
it's got a very thin like cracker-like
crust
okay all right well yeah if i next time
i'm in st louis i will check that out
all right see you all right my friend
thank you for the call appreciate it
let's go to um i think this is either
alexa or alexander or alexandra
in los angeles
alex in los angeles you're on the air
and alex alexandra whoever is gone let's
go to william in vegas so william in las
vegas nevada you're on the air
william in las vegas nevada please
unmute yourself and then you'll be able
to talk to me
all right no william in vegas there very
very interesting
let's go to jojo in either austin or
australia i just see it says aus
is it austin texas or australia
no boy
austin australia you're on the air
no dice there let's try
jason from montreal you are
on the air hello david how are you doing
today
good how are you doing pretty good um so
i've been a fan for multiple years i
love your show you've been doing a
wonderful job at covering everything in
u.s politics you're honestly my go-to
show
pleasure um just wanted to make a few
points here basically
so uh republicans say they're pro-life
basically but they're anti-universal
health care anti-living wage
anti-mass pro-war anti-climate change so
basically
they they're against taking any action
to sustain
our planet past our current generation
so other than banning abortion for
you're forgetting that they're they're
they do want to ban abortion yeah
definitely so i always thought it
wouldn't be wouldn't it be easier for
democrats to show how they're mo
more pro-life than republicans by saying
how they're easier
how therefore easier access to higher
paying jobs reducing match of
massive wage disparity in conserving
existing life
same could be applied with universal uh
with ubi basically so
i mean it seems like an easy point to be
arguing in u.s politics to be honest but
you are as you know one how many you're
10 correct you're 110
correct and it just has not worked now
whether it hasn't worked because
democrats are terrible at messaging
or it hasn't worked because it's not as
pithy but republicans george lakoff has
written about this a lot
republicans have been winning the
messaging war you are completely right
what is pro-life
about a republican platform pro-life
just means anti-abortion
but in terms of extending and improving
life on the planet
it is it is not i don't even want to
make it about party
it is not the right that is for those
things you're completely right and
due to a combination of republicans
getting
getting being early to the game of the
messaging and democrats being terrible
at messaging
it's it's proven more difficult than
what you're suggesting but you're
completely correct definitely and i just
wanted to make another point here
basically
uh so my girlfriend about two summers
ago i got um
got pneumonia basically in the middle of
summer she could barely walk without
being out of breath
yeah she's had respiratory issues ever
since she was born so
we managed to get to a hospital she was
plugged into a veiler ventilator on and
off for about three hours and we left
basically with a prescription for
additional pumps
and a temporary one costing about 80
canadian which is
absolutely nothing um so without of
course
any out-of-pocket costs i can't imagine
how much this would have cost
in the us basically you don't want to
know you don't want to know it would
have been
certainly thousands and thousands of
dollars definitely it's really scary
well
thank you very much david for for taking
my call i really appreciate it and
have yourself a wonderful day my
pleasure great to hear from you
let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because i'm going
right back
to viewer and listener calls right after
this short break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me and my medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right we're continuing to hear from
people via discord
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go uh next
to uh why don't we go oh i don't know
there's just so many interesting
locations let's go to sean from san
antonio texas next
hello can you hear me yes i can hey
uh david uh yeah just got into you here
about a year ago
um but i did have a question is that i
just
yesterday i i have a roommate here that
we're both on kind of
different political ends of the spectrum
okay and
i'm starting to go and uh kind of get
some like whispers of different
you know farther right kind of cue stuff
and i kind of had to go and actually sit
down with her and kind of have like a
discussion of like hey like so what's
going on and try to
meet in the middle if that makes sense i
don't know how you meet in the middle
with
q stuff but it sounds like you were kind
of trying to stage an intervention of
sorts which is good
yeah yeah i'm just trying to understand
it more and what i kind of ran into as
the circumstance
uh yesterday was kind of the situation
where
um i was kind of wanting to at least
have the the conversation because it
kind of got to the point of
uh she was so emotional that she was
like crying kind of like
why is this happening and kind of having
like anger and disgust of what's
happening in the country
but wait a second we need to clarify
that because if you're talking about a
cue
was she crying because they stole it
from trump or was she crying because
there were violent riots incited by
trump
oh well i mean the the specific thing
that she brought up was that um
the media is going and saying that
antifa
are they oh no wait what was is that
antifa was the one that actually went
and stormed the capitol okay okay
and and i kind of just let that one go
because i'm not gonna
i i'm having to live with this person
yeah completely delusional but you can't
do anything about it
yeah and so but but with that um
circumstance the the situation i ran
into was that
they um wouldn't want to engage and and
i understand that we're not going to be
able to kind of meet in the middle
as we were talking but yeah um what
would you say
in going and um deprogramming
the the conversation to get people to
start understanding that like
you know that this is what happens in
life like i i had to go and live with
a kind of a crazy four years the last
four years and you know you
you didn't have your side win and that's
kind of what it is
and we kind of need to make it past that
but i i wish i could look for
suggestions
unfortunately the the cue stuff
you know some of these people are so far
gone that i mean listen
think back to the jim jones cult
were you gonna be able to just pull
someone aside and say hey you know this
is pretty wacky you should quit
obviously that's not going to work
there's a level of radicalization
and and uh a true belief as they see it
i don't know what i really do not know
when someone is in that deep i feel like
you almost have to say
this person is lost and maybe we'll get
lucky and something will happen by
chance to change
their mind but let's focus on fixing
education culture and media literacy
to prevent someone from even being
susceptible to this in the first place
because i don't know how you
de-radicalize someone that just
someone like your roommate i don't know
yeah yeah well
it's definitely a a work work in
progress or at least trying to go and
keep
some civility yeah with that in the
switch to change is that
um what would you have as guidance
towards going
and kind of enacting or being more a
part of that change
if that makes sense because i'm now with
kind of everything that's been going on
been getting more kind of into it but
i'm still kind of i guess
looking for the next right steps to go
and start pushing towards
agendas that are a little more in the
positive for people
there's no shortage of ways to get
involved if you want to get involved
with education i mean it depends how
local you want to go but you i mean
there's so many ways to affect positive
change in our communities get involved
in local races when there's a candidate
that you believe in and that you think
is going to make the changes that you
you want to see
if you think that part of the problem we
have is the electoral vote get involved
in pushing the national popular vote
interstate compact if you want to focus
on
uh get no longer filling up
prisons with non-violent drug offenders
you can get involved with
drug policy i mean there's re you have
to there's so much you just have to
figure out first
where you can't focus on everything
figure out what you what is most
important to you
and then figure out how to get involved
in that specifically
got it well i appreciate it david you
have a great rest of your day
my pleasure you as well uh great that so
many people want to get involved
that's uh that's that's the start for
sure
let's go next to fran from philly fran
from philly you're on the air hello
yes you're on there okay yeah um big
canada show i've been watching for a few
months now
up until uh
okay so my friend in order for me to
hear you
you're gonna have to figure out if
there's a piece of paper or a banana or
a shirt sleeve
rubbing up against your microphone or
what it is because every time you talk
it
we just can't hear you can you hear me
now yeah that's much better
okay okay so i just wanted to get
i just wanted to get into this thing i
saw on twitter
okay so this guy named eric fernandez he
has a
he has a long twitter thread going on
and he's basically saying
that members of congress are colluding
no he's basically saying that members of
congress colluded with um the terrorists
for example um ayanna presley said that
her panic buttons
were were removed for were removed from
her office
and clyburn also that his unmarked
office
was looted but marked office um remain
untouched right so let me explain that
second thing so people know
congressman clyburn says he believes
that there was some inside job
aspect to what took place because he has
two offices he has his office that is
his office as
as congressman with his name on it and
then he has an unmarked office
where i believe he's the majority whip
where he works as majority whip and that
only insiders would know about the
unmarked office and the location
otherwise they would just go to the one
with his name on it i've i've seen that
i don't know the truth of it i want to
be clear that a lot of this stuff
is being asserted and if if these things
are true
there have to be answers i don't know
and i want to be careful about asserting
things that i don't yet know more about
but
you're right these these allegations are
being made
yeah so how do we move on from this if
um
these things going to be true how do we
um
come together with the republicans
i mean listen i i hate to say this but i
don't know that there's any coming
together with the current
republicans i it's it's terrible just to
have to say it that way
but how is this republican party
that it either is trumpist or stood
aside
while trump destroyed the country
because they decided it was best for
them
how do you work with them i do i don't i
don't know i don't know that it's
possible sadly i wish i had something
more optimistic to say
thank you so much my pleasure friend
thank you
a depressing call uh but an important
call
certainly uh let's go to isaac
from ohio next isaac from ohio you're on
the air
oh god hello how are you good
what can i do for you so uh forgive me
if this is completely incorrect because
he's not
taking a single economic class or
anything okay but
uh i know that you're you're like a
social democrat
you're not in favor of like full-blown
socialism right but um
i came up with an idea a little while
back what if
um instead of like
outlawing like capitalism to go to
socialism because that would be too
complicated it's like
i don't i don't know what if we take um
what if we like defined uh like wage
slavery properly
okay and outlawed that like you couldn't
just
like the common practice of just hiring
someone paying them a flat rate for
their labor
where they have no ownership of their
workplace if we like
at least gave workers some ownership of
their workplace in all cases
i think so you're saying somebody kind
of some kind of law
that says every employee must be given
partial ownership of their place of
employment
yeah i don't see how you get that done
legally i mean i i don't i don't even
know that it's
i i think that the way to do it so that
would be a very authoritarian
imposition and check out my interview
with the uh
with the youtuber vosh who is a
socialist
but he said that the way that as he sees
it the way you're going to implement
these things is going to be by
convincing
businesses and others that it's a good
idea for
them to do it rather than imposing it as
law that that
i i hope i'm not wrong in summarizing
his perspective that way but
even he said that the types of things
you're talking about are very
authoritarian and
would essentially be uh uh dead ends um
and
and i think that he's probably right
about that i think what you're
suggesting would be very
would essentially be impossible to do
you you would just be saying
you you would be mandating you were
trying to force companies to do things
that there's no legal basis to force
them to do
it's less about economics it's more
about the law
okay you're just you're not particularly
against something like that you're just
saying it's not um
realistically possible so as a so as a
social democrat i'm not in favor of what
you're describing but for me it's not
even really the main
issue because it's just you're you're
not going to get it done in the in the
way where
there's just a law passed and it says
all employees are now owners
yeah well i'm not trying to make it that
simple like what if
if uh we say like the lowest tier of
workers have to own
like at least 20 of the entire company
collectively like is is that something
that could work
or i don't see i don't see how you get
it passed i mean i think the
the more important thing would be to for
you to think about this less as an
economic thing but more as a
how do you how do you get what is the
legal structure where you could do that
where government could do that
is it federal and is it state and if
it's one versus the other how do you
actually do it
and i i just don't see it i think if i
were you i would focus on how you get it
done rather than whether it's a good
idea i just don't see how you ev
how you ever get that done yeah i see
that's a really good point
yeah all right my friend though i
appreciate the call
yeah thank you all right pleasure uh
let's take a couple of others because
there
are many people many many people
who want to chat why don't we
try um let's go to
is it yan from norway yan from norway
sir yes sir how are you
i'm good thank you are you good safe
yeah yeah are you in oslo or where are
you
well i'm about one and a half hours
drive away from myself so
okay yeah how much uh how many hours of
sunlight a day do you get right now
um well during colby
if i like look out the window i get some
but uh
no no no i mean not not you personally i
mean where you are
yeah yeah no we have i was just joking
we have about like
uh six to seven hours i think okay all
right
yeah no i was just wondering like
um because looking looking at the
situation from norway like
how um how do you think you can like
fix um like
reclaim your integrity do you think it's
enough
do you think it's enough like trying to
put trump in his place because
i i can see it like even if you don't
manage to impeach him or
like giving giving him some some
larger repercussions yeah just
trying that will send a really good
signal
like it's a good signal just trying to
impeach him right
but it is um if he's not convicted
you're saying listen i think the
rehabilitation of the united states is
partially going to happen
from just having joe biden in the return
of actual
diplomatic uh uh taking diplomacy
seriously i really do think that
many countries are eager to get back to
a normal relationship with the us so i
think just having joe biden back
and a proper diplomatic core and
ambassadors i think that will be a big
piece of it but i don't think that will
be enough
i think the u.s is going to have to
become a leader on coronavirus and and
uh to to regain some of the respect that
we lost under donald trump
i think the united states is going to
have to figure out you know trump
bailed on the iran deal for no reason
iran didn't break any of the rules
during the deal
the u.s is going to have to figure out
how to regain credibility there so i
think that
it will partially happen under biden
just because biden will be normal
but i think that there is still work to
do i don't think it will ultimately be
about whether the senate convicts trump
on impeachment
no no no but just sending the signal and
trying that's that's
yeah thank you man my pleasure john from
norway all right make sure you're
getting that uh vitamin d there
um thanks to everybody who called i am
out of time
for today but i will take calls again in
the future
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just
a feel-good thing you get access to the
world famous
bonus show every single day just for
members
as well as commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay uh let's get into audience
questions for the week
many of them related to the really
tragedies that we observed in the united
states over the last week and a half
first question david
we have the biggest military and most
militarized police in the world
why couldn't the capitol police keep
rioters out what the hell happened and
this is
a question that became an important one
very quickly uh after we as we were
witnessing the events of january 6 the
riotous
insurrection fomented by president
donald trump and it is true
the government spends hundreds of
billions on defense
on the military department of the
defense pentagon
department of homeland security on and
on and on
how is it possible that you ended up
with a situation where a mob
breaches the capital the vice president
and members of congress
are are there secret service
and other evacuations and and the within
minutes this mob
i mean we were watching it and it wasn't
very long after the debate started into
the objections over
arizona that the mob had overrun the
building and people needed to take
shelter and on and on
so there are two big picture answers and
we'll dig into each of them
one big picture answer is they didn't
understand the scope of the threat
the other big picture answer is they
understood the scope of the threat
and chose not to be more prepared and
there's
a sort of more benign uh at least as
motives go
explanation for that and the more
conspiratorial one so
let's start with the most conspiratorial
because i'm not going to spend a lot of
time of it
absent evidence and the conspiratorial
version would be
everybody knew exactly what was going to
happen and the reason police weren't
prepared
is because police slash whoever is in
power
were in on a plan to allow this to
happen
for whatever reason to make someone look
good or make someone look bad or to
suggest a pretext for trump to declare
martial law that's the conspiratorial
conspiratorial when police were in on it
and
so far i've not seen evidence of that um
don't attribute malice when incompetence
adequately covers what we've seen
so then we get to the capitol police
didn't know what to expect
versus they knew what to expect and just
didn't
didn't prepare enough there are reports
about the capitol police rejecting
some federal offers for help both in
advance of and in the moment of what was
going on
it still has to be investigated and if
it's true
that capitol police rejected further
offers of help
then that's a disaster and it has to be
investigated
why did leadership refuse the help what
are the explanations
and that needs to be looked at and then
the other side of it would be
they simply didn't realize the risk that
was posed
and they were caught unprepared and that
also requires an investigation because
we're talking about
securing the capital when the vice
president is going to be there
at a time crucial to american democracy
so either way it would be a failure we
just have to
have to figure it out now from a very
you know logistical rote
perspective um a lot of this
has to do with lack of
enough perimeters and you know there's
just crowd control stuff like i don't
know if people are
looking for an answer that's very
specific to crowd control but
when you have such a large crowd
it has to be managed earlier it is true
that trump hesitated and ultimately it
seems he was even mike pence who sent
the national guard
once things were going on it is true
that it took a while for
state troopers from virginia and others
show up to show up that's all true
but the reality is it's already too late
at that point to try to retake control
of a scene when it has already
degenerated to what it had degenerated
at that point in time by
1 40 1 50 pm eastern time on wednesday
it's too late
large crowds of protesters have to be
managed earlier
the capital should have been surrounded
and secured earlier
with multiple perimeters and in addition
to that
the crowds should have been directed
even when they were blocks away they
should have been redirected and that
that's the only way you can manage
and direct a crowd that large because it
didn't happen
the protesters were able to start
congregating in large groups
already close to the capital and then
you had another failure which was as we
saw the barriers breached
still you know kind of far from the
capital
at that point the number of officers
left on the capital steps was too small
to control what was happening and so
the perimeter was pushed further back so
some of the analyses we've seen are that
it was completely unthinkable
not to have multiple layers of police
cordons on the outskirts of the complex
and even further out
fences and barricades there were some
but they're useless unless you're
properly directing the crowd
you have to start making arrests early
very importantly understand that
when the first people started battling
with the officers at the barriers
near the capitol yes there weren't
nearly enough officers and yes they
never should have been that close in
groups that large
but nobody got arrested and you could
say well the police were overwhelmed how
can they start arresting people right
away it's fair
it was all completely mismanaged but one
of the things you want to do is you need
to start making the arrest
early you need to immediately target the
people that seem most violent
some of the people that were earliest
most violent on video
they stuck around for hours and
eventually made it into the capital so
everything everything that happened was
was done wrong by the way
i'm speaking in defense of the officers
in the sense that early there were
people already being violent with the
officers hitting them
with the barriers themselves the people
being violent with officers need to be
arrested
right away and and they weren't so
everything went wrong
the motives and explanations we still
don't know but from a logistical crowd
control standpoint
everything went wrong in the sense that
none of the stuff that should have been
done was done and
we'll learn more about it i'm sure in
two months when some report is published
that
nobody will see but we'll pay attention
for and we'll take a look at
david what do you believe the
consequences will be
to the trumpest coup insurrectionist
riot
so it's still too early to know but for
me
the questions are what will be the
consequences
for trump and the republican party i'm
going to deal with that in a second
segment because that requires
much more time on its own what will be
the consequences for the rioters
what will be the consequences for the
country and what will be the
consequences for joe biden who's about
to be sworn in in the midst of
absolute insanity so for the rioters
it's quite simple this now becomes a law
enforcement
operation um the rioters need to be
identified
and they need to be arrested processed
charged and get them into the justice
system and start working through
uh what what is going on many of them
already have we've started to see
you know collections of trumpist
mugshots be put together
and these are folks who should be dealt
with seriously we already talked about
how
how would this have gone differently
were this a group of black protesters
antifa black lives matter it would have
been dramatically different from the
start well we're beyond that
now the question is how is the justice
system going to deal
with these folks and we need to
uh see that process through and for the
rioters
listen many of them are many of them
have lost jobs lawmakers have resigned
um we have seen people ostracized by
communities
we've seen all sorts of different things
you know a lot of people get their lives
ruined
via interactions with police that never
even should be police interactions
here some people are going to get their
lives ruined or at least temporarily
ruined
uh because they made really bad
decisions and did did horrible things
and so
that's that's the the path forward for
the rioters
for the country i had a segment on
monday about this and
we're really at a precipice we shouldn't
understate you know i said this when we
were voting hillary versus trump in
2016.
anybody saying trump hillary it's the
same
anybody saying i don't really know that
in practical terms it's much of a
difference
they were wrong and we were talking
about the importance of that decision
four years ago
and likewise we are either going to see
the country
recognize that even though we're not all
on the same page politically that what
happened over the last 10 days goes
beyond politics
and that it cannot be allowed in any way
it can't be allowed in our communities
at a microcosm level
uh it can't be allowed at the federal
level at the state level that this
this is not valid politics and that
would be the ideal thing and
as i said it's going to require some
republicans to say i don't like what
trump
uh how trump did his presidency i am for
things like low taxes low regulation etc
that are typically more republican
things i don't see them in joe biden
but joe biden is the president and we
have to come together and simply respect
that it doesn't mean we don't disagree
when joe biden does something we don't
like and that applies to us on the left
as well
that's one path forward the other path
forward
is that this type of riotous
insurrection becomes
unfortunately more common and considered
valid politics by too many people
and it's a very dangerous precipice so
what what it means for the country
we will soon see for joe biden
i i actually think that to some degree
this has been good for joe biden and i
want to be really careful there's never
anything
good in in in practice from
these riotous coup attempts or what we
saw
but there is some degree to which
i believe and hope more people than
otherwise would be
are better predisposed to the biden
presidency because it means trump goes
and that that has to happen and so i
think that
democrats could not possibly if you had
said to democrats
what can you come up with that would
happen within two weeks of biden
swearing in that would best position
biden
to get started i don't think they could
have come up with anything
more beneficial than the trumpist right
completely humiliating itself now i know
lots of people liked what the trumpist
right did there are millions of people
who support what the trumpist right did
but there are many many republicans who
don't and when it comes to the officials
who said oh you know i'm quitting now
it's too little too late chris chris the
lisa murkowski betsy devos it's too
little too late guys you don't get to
have your reputations rehabilitated but
for the presumably millions of trump
voters
that are disgusted with what's going on
i believe their disgust will better
position joe biden for his entry into
office and
and that's my hope whether it will work
out that way or not
remains to be seen now let's talk about
what this does to trump and the
republican party
what will be the effect of the trump
coup
riot on the future of the republican
party and many of you asking me is it
the end of the republican party
this is not the end of the republican
party the republican party
and by that i mean the republicans that
remain in the public eye
they uh they they are not people of
substance
okay lindsey graham denounced trumpism
early in the 2016 republican primary
and then he embraced it and then he
partially called out some of the things
trump did
but then he golfs with trump and brown
noses him all the time
and just in these last two weeks before
trump leaves
lindsey graham gave a sensible speech on
the floor
of the house during that joint session
in counting the ballots saying
this has to stop joe biden as president
and then within 48 hours was on fox news
pleading mercy for trump who did the
right thing
and shouldn't be impeached a second time
so these people are of no substance
these are
weasels okay susan collins in a less
cartoonish way how many times has she
said well i'm disappointed
in the president i'm very concerned with
the president
and then she never once votes to make
anything change
so i expect that the republican
officials that survive
this some simply won't the republican
officials that survive this
are going to weasel their way out with
some of the both side stuff combined
with i did denounce this one thing at
this point they're going to pay lip
service as necessary
there's not going to be any real
introspection it will be just attacks on
democrats and liberals and
you know we're against violence type of
thing so the future of the republican
party is going to be determined not by
the republican electeds
we know what they're going to do it's
going to depend on republican voters
now when i say that many of you will not
be optimistic and i understand why
any party whose electorate can be
bamboozled into choosing trump in a
primary
and then voting for him 60 million 60
something million people in 2016.
and then 70 something million voting for
him in 2020 after everything we saw yeah
i don't have
high expectations for those people
either but
but um there is a degree
of this was too much
that we are seeing among some
republicans i'm not talking the
kiwinon insurrectionists that still to
this day are saying
antifa did the riot i'm not talking
about them they're probably beyond help
but i am talking about people who would
be more in line with
john mccain or mitt romney
or you know even somebody like william
weld the former republican governor of
massachusetts to go back a little bit
a lot of those folks see the difference
between what they believe and what
donald trump brought to the republican
party
and while i don't expect them to be
political allies in any real substantive
way on policy
they may require some kind of bigger
change within the party the republican
party
that uh would prevent another trump from
happening again
i'm not super optimistic i'm trying to
give you the best case scenario
and i think it's simply too early to
know it's you know uh
you you don't know to say what's the
damage when the when the hurricane is
still happening
is difficult to say you know if if
on if on september 12th we had said what
is the full political impact of 9 11
it would have been too early by that we
didn't know yet some of us
you know we may be suspected that a war
was coming but we didn't know that the
us would go to war with the wrong
country
on september 12th it would it was too
early so to some degree it's just too
early
but i'm giving you some sense of what
the best case scenario might be
uh we will be here with you next week
for the inauguration and swearing-in of
joe biden
hopefully not for any violence i hope
there isn't
any we are off on monday martin luther
king day
no show monday martin luther king day
we'll be back with you tuesday
and then wednesday live for the
inauguration as well i'll see everybody
then
enjoy the bonus show remember to sign up
at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25
percent off a subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with the
primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only ninety nine dollars a month
with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started